at the moment it's um it's now really
starting to build we're starting to get
challenges um around uh the the central
and southern areas but particularly in
the south um you're really a piece
reported
for issues on the m3 um we've had the
m48 bridge the old seven crossing has
been closed since 11 o'clock
11 o'clock last night
the qe2 bridge was closed in the wee
small hours of the morning and so you
can't travel over the bridge you're
having to use the old dartford tunnel so
um instead of having four lanes each way
there's now only two lanes each way
through the tunnel so that will cause
some additional knock-on consequences um
and then moving further afield we've
also got the a14 orwell bridge near its
switch closed
um if you are thinking of traveling
around the region and it's been
mentioned a few times please take your
time allow plenty of time if you do have
to travel but the key thing we would say
is if there is anything that you can do
tomorrow
that you don't need to do today then by
all means put it off till tomorrow
from six o'clock this morning across
gantries across about half of the uk
uh sorry half of england we've been
setting signs that say essential travel
only um and you really really do need to
think hard um about whether or not you
need to travel and just one thing that
um one of your earlier pieces uh was
saying around um any further updates and
information that we can give you um
just before 10 o'clock this morning um
all sailings between dover and calais
were suspended um there are two boats
due to leave shortly that are empty that
will make the crossing so that uh when
services resume
uh when it's safe to do so there will be
a couple of boats in each harbor so
there will be a balanced service um so
that's another one to be aware of so um
like you know with all forms of travel
at the moment please uh put in plenty of
planning allow lots of extra time if you
do have to go anywhere and also check
before you travel because we don't want
you to be out there going to an airport
only to find that your flight's been
cancelled anyway and you've had a wasted
journey and put yourself and also the
emergency services in some additional
danger and because um you know you're
moving around on the network
unnecessarily
there's very that's very very sound
advice if there's anything you can leave
till tomorrow leave it till tomorrow
when it comes to travel but if it's if
it's something you can't leave until
tomorrow
will it be safe for people to travel
tonight
um we believe that the winds will begin
to die down um
from probably around about six or seven
o'clock this evening
um unfortunately um eunice has been my
um unintended mistress since about
monday lunchtime
when we first became aware of the
problems uh that the weather was going
to bring i had my best mate dudley and
now i've got um my mistress um eugene uh
to uh to eunice sorry to uh to look
after
um but this will very quickly be
followed as the winds die down with an
awful lot of rain so here in the
midlands and once we get rid of the the
the strong winds
we're then moving towards planning and
preparing for flooding along the seven
estuary um so places like shropshire uh
worcestershire herefordshire and
gloucestershire um are my next um
you know my next thing that i need to
concentrate on from tomorrow so uh for
for us in national highways um it's
going to be an extremely busy next few
days
and just lastly in terms of
problems you've had with any hgvs on the
roads i've seen some pretty nasty
pictures today what's been the situation
when it comes to truck drivers
yeah we've worked very closely with the
road haulage associations
and what we've asked um hgv drivers
obviously is to slow down
be prepared particularly when you're
traveling north and south
because the side of the lorry pretty
much becomes
a parachute
and
we we've asked
hgv drivers who have curtain-sided
vehicles if they can fold the curtains
back if there's nothing in the back of
the lorry if they can fold the curtains
back
because the last time we had a daytime
storm of this magnitude um some sort of
eight 10 12 years ago
in my own region the west midlands
region alone we had eight lorries blown
over in the space of two hours so we're
very keen for that not to
be replicated again this time round and
actually curtain ciders empty curtain
ciders were the uh predominant they they
were actually seven out of the eight
lorries that were blown over so you know
it's a plea that we've worked very hard
very closely with the haulage companies
um and to be fair we've been looking at
the um the data and it does suggest and
particularly in the southwest so far and
we're starting to see that um
some of the numbers in the southeast as
well
numbers are
are down on what we would normally
expect for this time on a friday so
people are heeding their the advice
but obviously we need lots more people
to heed the advice stay at home have a
sofa day and watch sky news
okay frank bird thank you very much
indeed for joining us today thank you